MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So in this short
video, we'll talking
about the effects
of renormalization
and higher-order QED diagrams.
And we have already
seen that when
we perform the integration
of a matrix element over q,
that there's infinities.
And those infinities
can be gotten around
with by introducing
a cut-off scale,
and then only integrating
up to this cut-off scale,
and in effect
renormalize or redefine
masses and couplings involved.
So the first of such an
effect or effective higher
order is the so-called
vacuum polarization.
So you have high-order
contribution
which may look like this,
an additional loop, which
you can think about in the
photon is so energetic that it
can polarize the
vacuum and produce
a particle-antiparticle pair.
And that particle
and antiparticle pair
then provides kind of a
screening of the charge
you want to probe.
So I mentioned this
particle here emits a photon
and wants to probe the electric
charge of this particle.
The fact that there is this
vacuum polarization going on
screens the charge you
actually want to probe.
So effectively, you see
a charge which is either
reduced or increased,
depending on the impact,
on the sort of impact.
So the fine structure
constant, remember, alpha,
is 1/137 [INAUDIBLE] at 0.
We measure that the value of
alpha slightly increases as we
go to higher and
higher energies.
And so this has been
measured in many places,
experimentally
confirmed, for example,
at lab where, at the
[INAUDIBLE] of the W
or the scale of the W
mass, the value of alpha
has been measured to 1/128.
And you can do
this analytically.
You can calculate what the scale
of effect is and plot this.
So you see here the running
of alpha QED as a function
of the energy scale.
And you see this increase here.
There's another
interesting point.
As you open up new particles
of higher masses, quark
and antiquark pairs,
you find this kind
of stepping approach here--
the new particles, for example.
The muon, antimuon, and
the quarks and antiquarks
are [INAUDIBLE].
All right.
So this is the first
effect, vacuum polarization.
The second effect is very
interesting-- probably one
of the most famous
higher-order processes in QED.
And it has to do with the
anomalous magnetic moment.
The magnetic moment is
defined as the factor
g times e over 2m times S,
the spin of the particle.
Diagrams of this form
here modify the vertex.
So instead of having
a vertex like this,
you have higher orders which
modify the [INAUDIBLE]..
This leads, then, to a
modified magnetic moment
of the fermion involved--
in this case, an electron,
but it can also [INAUDIBLE]
muon or tau or another form.
So this was shown by
Schwinger already in 1948,
and then experimentally
confirmed many times after.
This g minus [INAUDIBLE],,
which is 2, leading order,
is modified to 2 plus pi over
alpha in next leading order.
We can calculate
this to many orders,
and with mind-blowing precision.
So the precision is better
than 10 to the minus 12 pi now.
I think it's 1.7
[INAUDIBLE] at this stage.
And experiments have
tried to measure
this to find new effects.
I mentioned you can
have new particles which
make modifications to
the magnetic moment here.
And you would have
sensitivity by making
experimental measurements.
So the electrons
[INAUDIBLE] muon g minus 2
has been measured with
very high precision.
No new physics
have been observed,
but some differences
are small differences
that have caused
quite some excitement
about further improvements
in g minus 2 measurements
specifically for the muon.
So they're ongoing
at this point.